Okay. I have to try this
just because it's disgusting.
So tell me what the name of
the candy is again. Pulse pit
spell that. P. U. L. U. L. S.
E. It's a green mango candy.
Yeah, it's originally,
it's a classic snuck right
where they use the sulfur salt.
It's called black salt and they'd put a
bit of Chili and sulfur salt on mango.
And I have to admit that when I had the
real green mango with the sulfur salt is
not that bad. That candy was like pushed.
It's like the mega warheads, you know,
that we had as kids.
I wonder too sometimes like the Gamey
flavor of the pheasant, the cheese,
that is the yield of that is it? I see it
sometimes as a bit of a, like, you know,
the ghost pepper is a bit of a pissing
contest between, yeah. You know,
like it's like no one could possibly
enjoy the taste of ghost pepper. No, no.
I mean, does it even have a taste? I
mean, you even responding to that taste,
I won't even try it. Have you, you know
who you know, who loves that? You know,
Olivier, those guys, they have like
what they watch, like game of Thrones,
they get together and they,
those peppers, oh yeah,
they have like Olivia all bone merciay
who's a fighter in the UFC and they'll,
they'll have like ghost pepper parties,
you know,
and then the next day they'll
go to comicon and dress
up as superheroes and then
play some online poker and
then eat more ghost peppers.
And he's also a UFC fighter. You got to
think he's a very extreme human being.
These are funny kid. I was
very, very, very nice guy guys.
Brilliant to know that
he was a trained killer.
You would have no idea if you talked to
him. It just seems like a jail. Yeah,
he's a sweetie could kid. And it's a good
for us. It's interesting. You know, we,
we actually have a bit of a chapter in
the book where we talk loosely about
those guys and that relationship where
you guys sponsored him or something.
He four before the Reebok thing.
Yeah. Because I remember one,
one of the fights that we did in Montreal,
um,
we went to your restaurant afterwards
and Livier showed up after his fight and
you guys were congratulating him on
his, uh, his fiance's, his wife works,
his girlfriend works with us at the
restaurant and for a long time now and uh,
you know, we met because these
guys, it's, it's interesting. Hey,
there's super into food and they're open
to a lot of things and they're curious
and a lot of them get aimed in
the wrong direction, you know,
like the brown rice and chicken direction
and you're responsible for in big part
for the awakening, the nutritional
awakening of these guys. You know,
a lot of them go for their gun license
and health just to be able to hunt.
They go fishing on the weekend,
they go for like two hours hike in
the woods and like little fishing rod.
They come back with droughts and we
get a phone call. He's like, Hey Fred,
I go fish for trout. You know, what
do I do with that? You know, it's,
it's a great thing. And Yeah, we
did. We did sponsored them after.
But then what we do now is we, um,
we cook for them a post way in,
ah,
Marco did GSP or the last fight at
Madison Square Gardens. They were,
the boys were there for
a week. Uh, we've done,
Tim Kennedy came for a week and just hung
out and cook meals. We sat in the kids,
uh, Marco and Fred goes and Gab goes,
uh, got real drunk polo. They'd go,
they rent a suite and they prepare
all of the meals up to weight cut and
afterwards.
And do they have nutritional requirements
for the weight cut and like just like
the weekend they do, they
have a nutritionist there
with them, but then they,
they have the crime.
But my,
I have a take on that is
if the nutritionist writes
a plan and the food's not
good and you don't eat it, then it
doesn't, it doesn't work. Right.
Like can even write on paper.
But if you don't take the pill,
then you don't eat chicken and Kale.
This much grabs this.
But we can professional cook,
we'll make the Kale delicious or Brussels
prize and the chicken properly cause
the Kale could be bad and the
chicken can be dry thing too.
That works that you guys
are already suffering.
The thing that works the best in that
case is that all of a sudden you have in
the room, we set up a
little table, which is,
so it's not like playstation dirty
underwear's like pre-fight vibe.
It's dining with dining with friends.
And whether it's Marco Gab me, we know
we don't talk. If you don't want to talk,
we want to talk, we're here, you know,
and we'll, we'll, we'll hang out.
But then you feel like
your eggs in that Tortilla,
you feel like your eggs with potatoes
or like it's mellow and it helps a lot
with the,
just the context of not being like
ordering pizza from room service.
George used to tell us whole
horror stories, you know,
but for some of his biggest wins years
ago with George say eating like room
service Rigatoni and pizza
before like a major fight,
you know.
So now it's different.